foreign
[Music]
this is Elliot filming a day in the life
of trigonometry and the crew you've
already met before nice to meet you so
yes as you can see the Green Room isn't
quite finished but we'll show the studio
hopefully you'll be more impressed by
that I like the green yes that was
actually some one of our team that
painted it well this entire space from
this wall to the very end of the wall
over there was one big empty room none
of this was here none of what you see
but this petition war was that this
partition wall was not there
the kitchen wasn't there the table
nothing was here all right and then if
you come and have a look at the studio
itself all of this is built you know the
brick wall the side walls that allow us
to have different signs of lighting on
the side all of this the storage room
everything we've done ourselves
basically so it's been Improvement on a
bed setting yeah exactly exactly what
we'll do is we'll get some drinks ready
oh and I need to go and do my makeup
actually so we act do you know that we
had a woman from one of the biggest TV
shows in Britain come and train it's
time to do our makeup
he's not talking to me just how it
should be makeup with KK
[Music]
first I don't know what this is but it's
some kind of photo finish smooth and
blur this is so my forehead is slightly
less shiny
well just my whole face really so as you
can see right now my face is a mix of
like red patches and black eyes because
Nikolai won't let me sleep and the idea
of makeup is to make very little impact
on that whatsoever because I still look
like that then we do the brown stuff you
go making me look even more Pakistani
than I already do
as you can see it creates a nice smooth
wait I'm sounding like some kind of
online influencer that sells makeup and
I did not expect this be the birds
are loving myself so the idea is we
basically smooth it out so my face looks
like it has a consistent skin tone which
it normally does we've done that
and this is the crucial bit earlier let
taint velvet I mean this is not natural
as I meant for a man
so this is for the black eyes she picked
two different shades that I have to mix
like that and like that and you sort of
blend it in proper Essex orange mate as
my wife said with the first time she saw
me do this makeup you actually look
healthy right so you can see the eyes
are slightly less black can we see that
can we see that no all right and that
ladies and gentlemen so you lose your
masculinity live on camera all right
let's do this I'm gonna have a great
interview with Nigel bigger some
business meetings then raw then an
intern Pierce Morgan it's going to be a
long day which is the days that we
normally have anyway did Harman tell you
how he he came to us
so he used to work in TV doing basically
what he does for us now tell Nigel the
story after the the George Floyd thing
in 2020 I I was always a bit satisfied
with TV being very prescriptive in what
you could say when you're making
documentaries you've kind of had the
conclusion already and it was what
pieces of evidence do we select to get
there that was your experience yeah
pretty much yeah after the George Floyd
moment they started sending these
bizarre emails out to their staff of
color saying um please tell us what we
need to unlearn and what we need to undo
we want to hear from you so I just I
kind of respond as a joke can you please
unlearn my email address
and they they started to kind of solicit
us for stories of our experiences in TV
that were negative with regards to our
race and I didn't particularly really
have any so they kind of stopped
emailing me but they found a bunch of
other people who had kind of stories
that were then kind of told to the
company and it was just this weird
impression put forth of like the whole
company was this kind of Cloak and
Dagger environment with all this kind of
quiet behind the scenes bigotry and
stuff everyone kind of looked at each
other knowing that this was not how it
was but that was just the sheer force of
that was the direction we were going in
so it actually started to make me feel
quite weird I kind of you know I was
very much treated on account of my race
not in like an overtly racist way but
also it was kind of not something people
could ignore you know so I just sent
these guys an email and said yeah
you guys I know you're racist yeah but
that's but it's kind of straightforward
so you knew what you were getting it's
not like a wine
I think for a lot of people it's just a
relief to be an environment and for me
and for us it's actually just where none
of that matters yeah we just care about
the work you know and we employ whoever
you know we and we talked about this
when we were open we have like someone
who works for us as gender dysphoria
someone who makes images for us who's
trans you know and and very diverse so
what we're saying is the system isn't
perfect we're trying to striving to be
white and male neither
exactly we're a Dying Breed mate yeah
should we go and do the interview yeah
cool let's go do it
this is where the KK Jackets live
it's tidy as you can see this gets
tidied once a week and it just returns
yeah well I just a Blazer no no you
don't need to sure oh yeah you look
great very fine the great it's a very
interesting story I was listening to you
on a podcast Yesterday by whatever
research I think before the book came
out he said I can't think of anything
more counter-cultural so I just got the
impression he was nervous the princess
I'm partly important I was going to say
it's much better to be feared for your
controversial nature than to be ignored
absolutely so I prefer to think he was
terrified
all right we're ready
hello and welcome to trigonometry good
to hear Nigel that's us thank you very
much it's been a pleasure there we go
fantastic
great you do such a good job you two are
we just uh uh um I mean it's a tool that
pleasure to speak to you you ask
interesting questions and just in terms
of your contribution to
public discussion really important all
done thank you thank you we appreciate
you being on here oh the interview is
brilliant uh really really enjoyable
great fun and it's one of our favorite
things at trigonometry for both me and
Constantine and the viewers and
listeners to get a historian on it just
it's one of our favorite ever episodes
about Nigel specifically you could have
said you know Nigel is one of my
favorite guests no two historians
you know what you know what I like about
my wife is women are great yeah I mean
let's not go too far
you're gonna give Nigel a copy of my
book in case he gets bored on the toilet
on the train or something
what runs out of toilet paper or runs
out of toilet paper as Ella helpfully
said he's now fired by the way no wait
no Ellie you're gonna make this
then you're fired
here we go
great don't just throwing ideas around
and we wanted something that would be
sort of like half a trigger warning half
incitement to like this could be
interesting right and you let me know
when this comes up
great to see you thank you very much
my mum knitted this you know
she's very proud as am I it's very nice
you know I'll have a lampshit as well
okay
and whatever you're having okay cool
thank you may seem like wasteful
spending by the way uh but it's not
because we don't we do actually cook
quite a bit just we literally have no
time today we got here the guys had to
set up then the interview now we're
gonna have a couple of meetings then
we're doing raw then after all I'm I'm
doing Pierce Morgan to slag off
garalinica which he deserves and then
pack down put out a clip from raw so we
won't be out of here until about 10
o'clock so that's how our days usually
are especially Thursday Friday Saturday
when winter party wouldn't want to do an
interview particularly on a Saturday
because
I always forget
so we've got the breakdown for all so
this rule we're going to be covering
lineker and broverman as well brogman
the Home Secretary has said she's been
deeply offended by Gary lineker's
comments because everyone's
deeply offended now because her husband
is Jewish uh number four is the New York
Times always a great publication would
you date a podcast bro
and number five we'll be talking about
Rogan's comedy club which opened a
couple of days ago done mate all right
thanks mate
all right Parcels are right my name you
should meet usually means Anton oh
Anton is spending company money well
Laura smart uh got us an Xbox
and uh he's bought us whatever the
this is is it wireless controller
anyway I actually whilst you're doing
Piers Morgan I might have a go on the
old Xbox I'll be going in games
I don't think so we never have time to
do anything I don't know why it's all
this to be honest yeah anyway maybe we
should have got Nigel bigger on me maybe
it's just so there's another controller
we only got one controller no but
there's a white one yeah yes we've got
two we do now oh what okay that's why I
was saying he's bought the second one
yeah yeah oh right I wasn't listening to
that bit
so we're just in the final stages of
sorting out our America trip it's really
exciting we've got some incredible
guests lined up we're going to go to a
couple of States we're not going to do
what we did last time which is go to
practically every state in the United
States because that meant that we nearly
died but we've got some amazing guests
lined up we're going to go to some
brilliant cities this is part one and
then we've got part two of America trip
coming up later on in the year so can't
wait for that right now as we're
recording this uh we're about a month
out from the trip so we've left it a
little bit late but that's what we
always do it's going to be all fully
recorded and also uh we're not going to
eat nearly as much as we did last time
Francis has been informed yeah
how do you feel about that Francis
Furious he's Furious
that's good it's is it's a ticket right
so we're waiting for Anton he's run away
as usual normally Francis does a lot of
the cooking and I do sometimes and so
does Anton uh but today we're very short
on time so we ordered the takeaway here
is Anton Anton there's some food food
over here mate and um yeah we're gonna
say grace Harman doesn't give a
he's already getting stuck in I'd like
to say grace after the meal you know
yeah when you're probably grateful
thankful then yeah
what we're about to receive the many
blessings that are coming our way but
also taking a moment to be grateful for
what we have and everything that we have
achieved and the wonderful people we've
met in our journey may we be truly
grateful amen
of who captured any other slaves anyone
in the museum right they literally
they're going over the Europeans to be
in popular media like great use of
company money I I bought it I'm kidding
me I'm kidding
[Applause]
see what they're making me do
ORS
two two walk just perfect
[Music]
all right here we go
let's get ready to Roar
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Morgan uh it's 8 30 and after this we're
finally going to wrap up well we've got
to pick a clip from the raw and the
title and thumb and then we'll be ready
to go Anton's gonna get home before
midnight tonight which is uh early we're
talking about Harry and Megan
is that what you're on to talk about
hey is that what you're on to talk about
thankfully not I want to talk about uh
Gary lineker but they're talking about
Harry and Megan do you feel like you're
back on down one
is this not exactly the problem thanks
Sarah man appreciate it take care
thank you
[Music]
foreign